ابقاء اللائحه الجمهوريه باقل عدد من
مرشحي الرئاسه هدف للرئيس الامريكي السابق
دون التروم تحضيرا لانتخابات العام المقبل
يوم امس حاول ترامب ثاني حاكم فلوريد
عن الدخول رسميا في السباق الرئاسي وقال
ان ذلك سيؤدي لتقسيم الحزب الجمهوري
والاضرار بوظيفه ديسانتسكا حاكم وعلى
منصته التروس سوشل كتبت ترامب ان حاكم
فلوريدا لا يبلي بلاء حسنا ضده في
استطلاعات الرايه اضافه ترامب ان ترشح
ديسانس سيفقده اصوات القاعده الانتخابيه
وانه لن يتمكن ابدا من الترشح لمنصب
الرئاسه بنجاح مره اخرى على حد قول ترامب
بحسب مصادر اعلاميه امريكيه بدات مجموعات
مؤيده لحاكم فلوريدا باستقطاب العديد من
الموظفين الذين عملوا سابقا من الرئيس
السابق ترامب في ادارته او حتى في حملته
كذلك بدا روندي سانتوس بالتوجه الى ولا
التصويت المبكر في الانتخابات التمهيديه
للحزب الجمهوري مثل اي واي وساوت كارولا
وفي حين لم يعلن ديسانس بعد نيته للترشحي
من عدمه لكن من المتوقع على نطاق واسع ان
يدخل السباق في الاشهر المقبله قناه فوكس
نيوز كانت اجرت الاسبوع الماضي استطلاعا
للراي اظهر ان ترامب يحظى بتاييد
54% من الناخبين من الحزب الجمهوري بينما
جاء ديسانتس ثانيا بنسبه تاييد وصلت الى
24%
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات